tell us about when this script came in
what your reaction to it cuz I think you
actually tweeted your reaction to it
when you read it more accurate yeah I I
had heard about this script from a few
people from actors and some writers who
knew it was very good and it kind of
just had a reputation for being one of
the best scripts out there and people
knew that and it was very exciting that
it was happening and when it came to me
I was really thrilled to get right into
it
and I think by page like 15 I yelled out
can they do that and I was really really
I was I was shocked that a script could
be so ambitious and tight like I was
really in awe of it being able to take
this emotional journey but also take all
these incredible pivots and somehow
remain intact and I just couldn't
understand and then I talked to Dan and
I thought okay this is an impossible
combination of things because I always I
have this algorithm which I actually
stole from Jon Favreau which I think is
really useful for all actors deciding
whether to do films you have three
factors you have your cast your director
in your script you can take a risk on
one it's pretty reliable and I wasn't
taking any risks on this because Oscar
was already cast and I was really
excited that wasn't a risk I was super
excited to work with him obviously the
script was was airtight and beautiful
and I really loved Dan's work and had
heard only amazing things about him from
everybody so that was my reaction I was
like woah hey let's do this but picking
up on Olivia's idea can you do this in a
script as you're writing it how much of
you how much are you consciously
thinking about conventions of screenplay
and trying to break those conventions in
terms of narration in terms of breaking
I don't know what it is in film is it
the fourth wall the fifth wall are you
consciously doing that as you're writing
no I mean my prior writing process if
there is one is it's a very stream of
consciousness I'm not trained I've I've
been taught on the job
to write a screenplay how to direct a
movie and so I was just writing I sat
down to write a story and I wrote it
over the course of the year let it
evolve I knew I was doing some weird
stuff tonally I wasn't doing it
consciously or or to make a point I just
kind of I this story started forming in
my head and I wrote it down
and it didn't go a lot further than that
did it start with an idea to start with
a setting to start with vignettes what
was the initial germ you know I sat down
I turned on my itunes shuffles and Bob
Dylan came on and and it was a time out
of mind the first song and so that
started I wrote this strange scene with
Samuel Jackson and then it went from
there and I really had no plan other
times in my life I've written films
Crazy Stupid Love or my first film I did
Danny Collins where I had the idea in
the plan this one was very it evolved as
I went and it did not there was no plan
good news and bad news is Bob Dylan yes
you like it getting the music riding
around the music what does that mean and
probably the producers have something to
say about this because Bob Dylan is
probably very protective of this music
what are those conversations like and
where does it go in terms of the songs
that you need to have and the lyrics you
want to use yeah I mean I wrote it like
Samuel Jackson I wrote Bob Dylan into
the film very predominantly without
obviously having ever met Bob Dylan and
so that became a process for the three
of us to figure out it wasn't something
that you could get around easily we had
a character named Dylan it's referenced
in the film and so my daughter Elvis
yeah yeah okay so we went the guys get
double but we went to New York and we we
sent the script and bob has this fellow
working form named Jeff rose and who his
the only client is Bob Dylan and he has
this the most incredible office it's
like a time capsule and they just a few
employers are there but it's been there
probably the same there 50 years
probably he's been in this place and
dannan Marty and I walked in and just
kind of started talking so I mean he
just started talking about Bob and sort
of playing us various different musics
and he had all the music that Bob had
written he could separate each of the
tracks and you've got to listen to the
drum track in this
we sat there for about an hour just
listening to like a dissection of like a
rolling stone I think it was right and
he just kind of broke this whole song
down it was like the most amazing music
lesson we walked out of there feeling
like well we got something from this if
anything we got that we didn't have the
songs yet but then he was he was a huge
partner for us to be able to he loved
the script he wanted it he wanted Bob to
be a part of this I want to ask about
putting the cast together I think Olivia
said that Oscar was already on board
after those initial conversations and
what were your conversations what did he
want to hear from you about the
character he was playing I mean I think
you know Oscars a tremendous actor and
obviously he's I think he's the actor of
his generation in that space and I think
he wanted to just he want he gets very
inside the character he wanted to talk
about a couple of things he was kind of
pretty on board he was in a place where
he was I kind of had limited time and so
he wanted to do it what happened was
once Oscars on board because he's on
page one of the script it becomes much
easier to get the ensemble that you
dream of and because you're able to say
I've got Oscar already and so it makes
you look like a better writer than you
actually are and so uh Olivia was next
and then I had worked with Annette
Bening before who wanted to work with
Oscar also and Olivia said lovely things
but I'm sure probably Oscar was a huge
driving force because who doesn't want
to like act for 40 pages with Oscar
Isaac and and then it just went from
there so it built upon itself I'm gonna
ask you about your editor about Julie
Monroe and and there's a lot of work
that's done editorially and I don't know
if it matches up page 4 page as you
wrote it what did you discover through
editorial that changed the film and how
would you describe your partnership with
Julie that's a great question and I
she's I mean she's exceptional I don't
I've done my two films with her and I'll
never I would literally win my editor I
would probably if my editor wasn't
available I would not do a film like
that's how strongly I feel about her we
you know the script of it that I first
wrote that Marty and Aaron read and
decided they wanted to make eggs almost
exactly what's on on the screen it
didn't really evolve we didn't change
any structure or any of that
the movie is such a complicated tonal
like balancing act that like it's all
between the lines in between the margins
and that's what Julie does really well
and so I as opposed to kind of going
through every performance and saying we
need this and that a it's a real subtle
tonal shift that hopefully works for
people where you're shifting tone
purposefully so in parts of this film
it's a straight up comedy like with
Samuel Jackson or other parts it's a
straight up romantic comedy and then the
parts it's very dark and very dangerous
and weird and so the goal is to
editorialize to be able to kind of
transition so it's not like so that they
recognize that something unusual is
happening but that there's still brace
for it so the example I give of what
Julie does does or did is after Oscars
suicide which is obviously the the kind
of create we've just lost both of these
characters surprisingly who we love and
I always worried will the audience be
able to come back from that and I really
genuinely and truly thought this one
film would come out in two movie
theaters and then if it caught it if it
caught a wind maybe it would get wider
because of that and what Julie did so
artfully was figure out a way to with we
figured out a way to you know hold on
after that moment so the audience has a
moment to breathe is this real your
brain should start going wait is this
real are they gonna do a funny thing
with the narrate the unreliable narrator
then holy [ __ ] this is real and then it
transitions and then you have enough
time and then the pace with which you
get back to Mandy Patinkin and the
little girl talking about the subtext of
what she's worried about is when the
audience starts coming back to life a
little bit and that is all about an
editorial balance of timing and pace and
tone that has nothing to do with the
writing or the performances and has
everything to do with how you manage it
when actors like you read this script
they can imagine and picture themselves
in it when somebody who's gonna finance
a movie reads this they probably have an
easier time picturing themselves not
being a part of it because it's a
difficult movie how did this movie get
made how did you get the money together
or still a little shock did it happen in
all honesty this script did a lot of the
hard work
it was a delivery just said it was a
script that Dan wrote on spec and was
out there that enough people would read
and it had been talked about so that
when it crossed our desks we had never
made a movie before and I knew Marty had
read it before us and it was just
something everybody kind of fell in love
with us included and that made it a
whole lot easier when you find something
that's spec script like this at this
quality level and it was it just
original so that certainly helps Marty
yeah you know I find that 90% of my day
ends in failure and I was I had failed
to get to produce four of Dan's scripts
beforehand just circumstances and so
when I got the fifth script
I actually was excited to read it just
as a fan so you know when you talk about
you know whether or not we can survive
what happens 40 minutes into the film as
I was reading it for the first time I
had that same moment like I stopped and
said wow you just killed your you just
killed both of your leads how are you
going to go from here and I had the
privilege of going on that ride for the
first time and as an audience being able
to say wow well he pulled me back in so
clearly it must be working but the the
honest truth with making this film by
the time we got it was by the time I got
a hold of it and was sort of beginning
to pitch Dan to let us be a part of it
Erin and film nation had also gotten it
and it actually came together kind of
quickly so Willie that wasn't the hard
part here and really it was Dan's the
thing that drove it was was Dan schedule
he had as you know he probably probably
knows he has a day job and he had a very
short narrow window and what she was
able to make the film that's what really
drove the whole thing to coming into
existence very very quickly so we
decided on a budget and we shot the
script what do you hope people take away
from this film what do you hope they are
having conversations about after it's
over catharsis and the idea of
interconnectedness of the human family
and our literal families I mean that's
what it really brought to me was a
an awareness of how I am just an
extension of my mother's story and her
mother's story and I you know ever since
I've had kids I've thought well your
children or your afterlife like that's
what happens after you die
there's even if they are your own
children like those stories are what
what we leave and I hope people sort of
have a chance to give that some thought
but most importantly for right now in
the world I hope there's a sense of
connection to people who are far far
away from us in different cultures
different countries just I think more
than anything that could probably heal
the world Marty Erin Olivia Dan thank
you so much for coming out thank you